Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and hopefully
you got a chance to see the Walking Dead Comic
Con panel I uploaded.
The trailer they showed at that panel is the
one you guys have all probably seen.
AMC is really nice about posting it immediately.
The movie’s that were there like Avengers
2 and Batman vs Superman, they don’t release
those clips.
I have no idea why, but this video is going
to be a breakdown of the Season 5 Trailer.
The Walker Shit has hit the fan.
Just in case any of you found me during comic
con or you're just now finding me.
I do weekly Walking Dead videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
After the breakdown I’ll announce the winner
of the giveaway.
So they pick up right in that last moment
of the Season 4 finale, rick’s final line
before it cut to the credits.
But they have that crazy Inception trailer
music that a lot of people have been using.
The bwaah sound.
I think the Godzilla trailer did the same
thing.
It’s just meant to put you into a state
of anxiety.
And I say mission accomplished.
On the plus side they cranked the lighting
up.
They shot the finale scene in there in almost
complete darkness.
I actually had to scoot up to my tv to distinguish
who was who.
It looks like they tear gas the train car
before storming in to subdue everyone.
But from the looks of it, everyone just bolts
the minute they get the chance.
All in the first few minutes of episode 1.
That table Rick sees as he hits the ground.
I think it’s safe to say that’s a body
being carved up, just like you’d carve a
side of beef.
More steaks for the grill.
Unless you want ribs.
Gareth has that cool creepy monologue where
he starts speechifying his “new way of life”.
The actor, Andrew J West, did that interview
on the Talking Dead special where he said
Gareth has this new philosophy about what
life in the apocalypse can be.
He made it sound really creepy and at the
time they had not confirmed everyone at Terminus
were practicing cannibals.
But I think that’s exactly what the “new
way of life is”.
And this trough that everyone gets tied to
look like what you’d slice someone’s throat
over so they can collect all the blood when
it pours out of you.
It looks pretty much like Bob fast talks the
shit out of Gareth into Eugene’s cure and
Washington, DC.
It jump cuts generic Terminus shots until
Rick is with Baby freaking Judith.
Reunion Time.
Which means Tyreese and Carol did make it
inside Terminus.
Then we see them on the road again with the
weapons cache.
You didn’t think they’d just drop that
story bit.
A hidden arsenal of automatic weapons.
Rick’s tearing down a Terminus poster foreshadowing
the fall of Terminus.
I love how Rick looks like Mel Gibson in Road
Warrior in this slow motion shot.
Which is funny, because they showed footage
from the new Mad Max movie at comic con too.
It wasn’t super clear earlier, but here
you can definitely tell they’re inside a
church.
Since Gareth is the only person with them
it looks like they’ve left Terminus, so
the trailer is jumping forward and backward
through the first couple of episodes.
This firehose Walker repellant isn’t at
Terminus, but the thing that grabs my eye
is Tera just casually sitting off to the side.
It might not be her, but it’s definitely
not a walker.
It’s just someone there to enjoy the water
show.
Lauren Cohan teased that in the premiere we
get to see people who aren’t badasses get
to be badasses and based on Bob Stookey going
all michonne on this Walker, I’m guessing
she was referring to him.
He’s come a long way from when Daryl almost
pushed him off that roof.
This shopping mall pit to hell is nice twist
on the Walkers falling from the ceiling early
in season 4.
All the water reminds me of the Governor’s
pirahna walker head fishtank.
Glenn Mazzara said that they developed a lot
of new looking styles of walkers we hadn’t
seen before and this guy here look pretty
new.
Loving the Carl and Michonne team up.
I’m hoping she teaches him to use her sword
at some point.
It looks like she’s modified it to be double
ended.
Which is just awesome.
This night time shot of the Church is probably
the one we’ve been seeing them in all these
scenes.
Rick talks about not going anywhere without
the rest of the survivors and it jumps back
to Terminus.
Back in the church Sasha says ‘you show
up and three of us are gone’.
She’s talking about Abraham, Rosita and
Eugene joining the group last season.
She didn’t meet them till Terminus.
But the ones so far that are gone are Beth,
Lizzy and Mika.
And here’s where all hell breaks loose at
Terminus.
Just look at all the walkers and the flames.
I just love this explosion.
I can’t imagine how many barrels of gasoline
it took to get a flame that big.
Here it just looks like Carol covered herself
in Mud on approach to Terminus.
I don’t think this is a new cast member
or anything.
Everyone is kind of freaking out about this
Glenn Baseball bat scene at Terminus just
because of the comics.
I won’t spoil what happens in the comics,
but it’s a pretty big WTF.
I don’t think he dies, just because he’s
in all these other scenes in the trailer that
look like they happen later in the story.
The baseball bat scene looks like it’s from
when they first get yanked up to that trough
when Bob Stokey stops them from getting all
their throats slit.
They will have a rotating cast this season
though, I’ll explain that later.
Here’s the first look at Seth Gilliam as
Father Gabriel.
I know the minute they announced he was cast
everyone wondered if he was playing Gabriel
in the comics.
They confirmed it during the Comic Con panel.
So I’m guessing all the church scenes we’ve
seen are from his church.
The real twist is that it looks like he didn’t
take Beth, she hasn’t been in any of the
church scenes and she shows up with a different
group of people later in the trailer.
I love how many of these random shots are
of Rick using the machine gun.
Let’s just agree to call him machine gun
Rick this year.
So
this shot is of the hospital they’ve been
filming at all year.
It seems like based on the number of days
they’ve spent shooting there, Beth is going
to be there for a long time.
No idea where it’s located on the map.
This is one of the new cast members who I’m
just going to call Lady Cop or Asshole Lady
Cop.
Her real life name is Christine Woods, but
we don’t know what her character’s name
is yet.
Or if it ties into the comics.
They’re the ones behind the crosses.
But Scott Gimple said even though they invoke
a lot of imagery from the saviors in the comics.
They’re not the saviors.
So that Lady Cop isn’t like a Lady Negan.
Even though the idea of a gender bent Negan
sounds exciting.
Beth’s storyline is supposed to be pretty
substantial and take place away from the rest
of the survivors, at least for a while.
So I’m guessing that hospital she’s at
is the home base of the cross people, whatever
their group is called.
And just to comment on the whole Terminus
escape.
It seems like based on the way the scenes
in the trailer were cut.
Rick and the group get Gareth to buy into
the Washington DC Cure story, so he let’s
them go to pursue it.
But Rick turns them around so they don’t
have to leave anyone behind and they grab
the weapons cache and let all the walkers
in and blow the place to hell.
Gareth is a cast regular though, so it seems
like he gets Rick to spare him and let him
travel with them.
So he’s going to be the Littlefinger of
the group, for Game of Thrones fans.
If you don’t watch that show, just think
of him as a person no one trusts and who is
a super creeper.
But let me know what your favorite part of
the trailer is and who do you think Lady Cop
is who’s smacking Beth around?
Walking Dead is back October 12th and yes
I will be doing weekly videos just like I
did for season 4 with a weekly giveaway.
It will probably overlap with my weekly Doctor
Who giveaway.
So you guys will have extra chances at winning
free stuff.
Quick shoutout to the winner of my comic con
giveaway.
Congrats to The Yowling Fox.
You win a Walking Dead Funko Pop figure of
your choice.
I’ll message you for details so be sure
to check your inbox.
My next Walking Dead video is going to be
a character breakdown for Daryl.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
If you saw him in the trailer he looked very
different from pre-Beth disappearance.
So his character will change just as much
as Rick’s character is changing.
I’ll try to post that on Sunday or Monday.
Right now click here if you haven’t seen
the comic con panel yet and click here for
a breakdown of the Batman versus Superman
comic con footage.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!